all right oh shut that the thumb fight
is roarsome I don't have my finger
either so ugly stop showing them okay
how do we get out of here ha hey burn it
yeah oh good for you sir
[ __ ] Merlotte's once I get the head
of Merlotte's I swear to God no one
cares about you literally well that's a
wheelchair hello
listen I suppose I should that's opening
it close it please I got talking to you
all right now let's get out of this
place for us what is this confidential
not dead named Oh [ __ ] okay what are
you doing sleeping I walk away a lazy
bum I can't really see anything I'm not
sure know that we can't go there hello
hello hello yeah how are we can go ahead
squeeze red blood a beautiful okay not
so creepy at all
wait what's our objective uh okay that
looks important no okay
what Oh Louis the fatty fat fat [ __ ]
ah ah what is this
there's no water in the system okay I'll
just turn them a big deal you just got a
hide first it's fine this is fine yeah
it's cold in here
[Music]
okay okay
James Brown
okay hallux button thanks buddy
yes excelencia I'm sure you'll never
find second one you can do throw me no
who's the pig now okay on the paper come
the pain I'm the pig I'm the pig I'm the
pain you're the pig
who's the pig and I'm to pick your the
pig the putting a bigger pool oh yeah
please don't hurt me please somebody
please don't hurt me please don't hurt
me god damn it you're not welcome in
here nah [ __ ] don't nest is no spawn the
back doors no come on he lost us let's
jump it [ __ ]
I fight stupid [ __ ]
spring bells you stay there if you think
about what you've died god dammit [ __ ]
alright let's find the other bottle I'm
Charlotte up in here lemon dill I love
Tim okay I got it I got it
so much chocolate
stupid [ __ ] danten danten teller intend
that other than the redundant dun dun
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun why am i
singing that song we made again you
[ __ ] bow game is not gonna touch you
I'm gonna let this steep so many
preferences Jesus Christ
alright we don't really do a little
battling now way is the other one what
are you know bad game bad game oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] up now done that's
bad Jack Spang
don't touch me don't touch me no you do
not gonna touch enemy yeah Mamma Mia
whoa what this are they said the planes
I closer than the Lord
ah good ah ah whoa whoa blood bags
lovely lovely lovely lovely hi there sir
wait
what hey that's my boyfriend let him go
don't touch my boyfriend get off me I
would punch you if I could but I am busy
[ __ ] around with Gabe well that's
what you get when you have too many as
spicy tacos or overdose and laxatives
there you are you little [ __ ]
yeah I know I know I found you I know I
found you hey bro my other half ass
whoa okay every little part in the
inside of his but I didn't think so
okay that guy's problems [ __ ] that guy
hi did we done Billy little in either
way let's just let's just get out of
here all right
whoa job that's good feet up okay all
right don't worry it's fine it's fine
that's right it's hi we're fine we're
fine we're fine waterfront
okay we're fine are you cereal yeah okay
okay now you let me go now you let me go
now you don't need let me go let me go
tonight
put your let me go Oh God my body just
[ __ ]
the sprinkles better work hi-oh
jab LUN okay new objective found father
martini outside I guess it's in here huh
no I guess it's in here huh I feel so
good I wonder where that fat guy went
actually it doesn't undid it's here
right no yes it is
we stopped the fire oh my god good job
that's an achievement scared by jumping
go Piltz go it's a [ __ ] miracle we
made it this far in this I feel like
you're a little high up it's this angle
weird I don't know I feel like your
brothers are looking down on me you're
normally do that well [ __ ] oh there's a
kitchen I used to have tits but now they
just flew off did you see that
I got a shake okay are you ready
I got a scared you - that is no way that
[ __ ] just got me oh god I'm not gonna
make out with you you'll never be my
girlfriend
Oh persistent are we huh
what up [ __ ] I was gonna cook you for
dinner
look it's cat oh no not Ken ah touch me
one last time Ken finger me ah can you
do what you do you do what you do and
don't watch your dough okay
well isn't me my nipples gets really
hard when I get scared it's awesome I
mean it's a defense mechanism
alright alright I don't really trust
this but uh you know look for him well
[ __ ] I live at least we're outside and
this for a site I'm not sure what we're
gonna do here I mean why would you have
to shut up thunder lightning
whatever your call okay what is that
saying how alive are you from a scale
from one to ten I'd say - fifty okay we
can't go there we should just bounce I
don't know okay
oh here we go here's something all right
progress thank you now where's that
bloody key there we go there we go
that's quite nice yeah batteries and the
moaning you know what is such what is
such are there ghosts in this game I
can't give supernatural things they're
not cool I'm not okay with that
game just want to tell you if then or
whatever your name is
calm down you give me a bad rep I told
everyone I'm famous for not being
skilled oh [ __ ] okay where
I swear there was a shed I swear to god
there was a shed it's at you shedding
they are all right bloody hail okay
we're here why can't I just bring this
awesome shovel with me as a friend
yep I'm not a fighter just want to bring
a friend all right
why does it have to be so goddamn dark a
minute it's okay it's okay it's okay
what I said I said ghost and now I'm not
okay with that I said no sorry
my bad my bad
not cool not cool
where the ghosts they didn't warn me
about the goals they don't deadly don't
deedily doggedly did not you to warn me
about the ghost oh [ __ ] we are so [ __ ]
we are so [ __ ] Oh Oh a ladder oh
that's so nice I'm just gonna go up for
it look in my bloody fingers ah come on
don't jump-scare me don't jump-scare me
don't jump-scare me thanks alright well
that went pretty good ten out of ten
pits chopped
Yolo see kids it works it [ __ ] works
everyone hates on Yolo Oh am I supposed
to go down there what is that guy doing
yo yo yo hombre batteries in the mine
and then in an anti manner
yes s para day oh [ __ ] I can't ah well
maybe another time
what's that noise down that nope aha
360 [ __ ] oh yeah you see that [ __ ]
I'm like a park or a girl
yep that's what they call me in school
except the girl part of course I promise
don't don't don't don't go there
it slipped out
well that was a lame way to go come on I
was right there
I hate with me like misty ed Sheila okay
it was my fault I take full
responsibility or you [ __ ] cereal I'm
not going through this [ __ ] again
alright y'all know McDonald's is that
toilet paper no silly me I have a
tendency of okay well this isn't so bad
I'll just go in here don't you dare jump
on me sir okay I get it Oh scary scary
Thunder I don't like it okay we know now
there are ghosts in this game but you
are out sir you are out [ __ ] idiot
okay well you got you gotta save her
what are you doing
batteries nananananananananananana no no
what are we going what's with the noise
hi hey don't [ __ ] that don't [ __ ] that
not cool oh you can't jump well [ __ ] me
okay where are we now
Oh
[Applause]
a duck in his natural habitat in the
grass fields of creepy mansions being
quite terrified but he makes it through
through his natural-born survive the
Lynx thing such as screaming like a
little [ __ ]
I'm sorry quacking being stuck like a
duck going on higher places to appear
taller
oh shut a dalit of course and being a
genius [ __ ] duck alright let's
go let's go which one which way that way
haha he's too fat hey fatty fat fat
can't go up he can't go what they can't
go up here all day oh he all day oh he
oh babe oh he
[Music]
okay we love and then we jump down [ __ ]
they're really dragging out the gameplay
here it's like what the hell am I doing
with my life
oh that [ __ ] hurt okay all right Park
it's a guy giving himself obj it's
pretty clear all the way there we go
I gotta end this episode here but I hope
you enjoyed watching maybe like if you
did house man like hit subscribe to
become a bird today and I will see you
in the next episode